if this page was folded along the dotted
line in the figure above the left hand
of the letter W would exactly coincide
with the right half of W you see that
right over there if you fold it this
point would go to that point right over
here this point would go to that point
right over there that point we go to
that point right over there and I can
keep going you have this axis of
symmetry right over here right down the
center which of the following letters as
shown cannot be folded along a vertical
line so that it's left half would
coincide with its right half so
encourage you to pause the video and
think about this on your own well let's
just think about each of these if I were
to drop a vertical line down the center
of a it looks like a is symmetric about
that there are mirror images on the left
and the right-hand side same thing for
the letter I same thing for the letter O
mirror images on the two sides same
things for the same thing for the letter
U now e.e gets interesting here we
aren't we don't have a mirror image if I
were to take the mirror image of this
point right over here we would get to
this point right over there if I were to
take the mirror image of that point
right over there well that does get you
there but this point over here there's
no corresponding point on the other side
here if I were to go here
there's no corresponding point right
over there so in order for e to been to
have been symmetric it should have
either looked like this it would have
either needed to look like this or if I
were to drop a line of a vertical line
here now this would be symmetric or if
it looked like this or if it looked like
this but obviously this is not what the
letter this is not what the letter E
looks like it does not look like either
of these symbols it looks like this and
this one does not have a line of
symmetry down its Center axis or a
vertical line cannot be drawn to have a
line of down its center to have a line
of symmetry here so this is the one that
cannot be folded along a vertical line
so this left half would coincide with
its right half